Tenemos la ecuación -16 igual a "x" entre 4 más 2 y queremos resolver esta ecuación con respecto a "x".
Eso, lo que significa es dejar a la "x" solita,
completamente solita de un lado del igual
y un bonche de cosas del otro lado del igual,
ok, esto es justo lo que vamos a hace ahorita.
Ahora, para lograrlo, un paso intermedio podría ser dejar "x" entre 4 solito de un lado del igual.
Y para hacer eso, simplemente tenemos que
deshacernos de este más 2
y la mejor forma de hacerlo es restando un 2, ok, porque 2 menos 2 es igual a 0,
entonces ya nos deshicimos del 2 y nos queda simplemente "x" entre 4 de este lado del igual,
pero hay un detalle muy importante aquí, ok, y eso es que esto de aquí es una ecuación,
este signo de igual significa que lo que está de este lado, es exactamente igual a lo que está de este lado.
Y si le restamos 2 a este lado del igual,
a fuerzas tenemos que restar 2 de este lado del igual,
porque esta es una ecuación y queremos que el lado izquierdo siga siendo igual al lado derecho.
Entonces siempre que tenemos una ecuación
y queremos modificarla, todo lo que le hagamos
a un lado del igual, se lo tenemos que hacer
también al otro.
Bueno, entonces, vamos a continuar, ok, de
este lado lo que tenemos es -16 más -2,
eso es -18 y esto de aquí va a ser igual a esta
cosa, que es "x"/4, "x" entre 4
y luego más 2 menos 2 y eso es simplemente 0, de hecho aquí podría poner un más 0, pero pues
creo que no es necesario.
Ok, entonces ya dejamos a "x"/4 solito de
un lado del igual,
ya estamos más cerca de dejar solito a "x", ya nada más nos falta deshacernos de este 1 entre 4.
Y bueno, la mejor forma de hacer eso, es multiplicando
por 4, ok, entonces aquí vamos a multiplicar
por 4 y como estamos en una ecuación entonces
también tenemos que multiplicar
por 4 de este lado del igual, ok, para que este lado
siga siendo igual a éste otro.
Y entonces, si tenemos aquí algo que se divida
entre 4 y luego lo multiplicamos por 4,
en realidad no le estamos haciendo nada a esta
cosa, cierto, este entre 4 y luego por 4 se cancelan
y por aquí lo que nos queda es, a ver, tenemos 18 y estamos multiplicando por 4,
eso es 4 por 8 = 32, 2 y llevamos 3,
4 por 1 = 4 más 3 = 7, entonces, 18 por 4 es 72,
pero aquí teníamos -18...
ok, teníamos -18, entonces esto es -72.
Así es que esta cosa de aquí es igual a
-72 y eso es igual a esta "x" solita, "x".
Y ¡Listo, ya terminamos!
"x" es igual a -72.
Ahora, estaría muy bien poder checar nuestras respuestas y lo bueno es que hay una forma
muy fácil de hacerlo, lo único que tenemos
que hacer es tomar la ecuación original,
esta ecuación de aquí y sustituir la "x",
ok, buscar en esta ecuación todos los lugares
donde aparece la "x" y en lugar de poner
la "x" vamos a poner -72.
A ver, la ecuación original es, -16 igual
a "x" que es -72 entre 4 más 2
y si en efecto se da esta igualdad entonces esta respuesta es correcta.
ahora -16 igual a...
nosotros sabemos por esta multiplicación,
que -72 entre 4 es igual a -18...
entonces aquí tenemos -18 más 2
y -18 más 2 es igual a -16...
-16... -16...
Entonces esta igualdad sí es cierta y por
lo tanto esta igualdad también es cierta
y entonces "x" sí es igual a -72.